let's examine the facts
yes fact fact fact fact great you're
fine
yes however
sometimes we look at the facts and
you're not fine
[Music]
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell in our last video we talked
about the setbacks that make founders
feel like [ __ ] when running their
startups
and this time we're going to talk about
how to prevent these punches to the face
and
how to take a punch and recover if you
absolutely must
so dalton i think the cool way to think
about this is a little bit like health
care there's preventative health care
and then there's you know treatment
so let's start with the preventative and
let's set the set the framework here
like
a lot of times founders get punched in
the face as almost unforced errors it's
like a result of magical thinking or
like other parts of their lives not
being set up and so
here are things you can do to either
reduce the number of punches that come
or at least reduce their intensity
because you have your other [ __ ] locked
up does that make sense
yeah exactly it's like
as we spoke to last time you can't think
that you're not gonna have any setbacks
and you're not gonna again take some
punches
it's gonna happen to you a hundred
percent that the highs are high and the
lows are low and so rather than assuming
you can be so smart that you will never
have low lows instead plan ahead
put the
infrastructure in place so that when you
do have these these big challenges or
these low moments
you have the infrastructure set up that
um you know you planned ahead for it i
think that's very
a very good idea so we were joking when
we were talking about
what to talk about in this video
a lot of these things could be put in
the category of adulting
and it might turn out that if you want
to be a founder of a very successful
company
you might have to adult
harder
than the people around you
in fact it almost assuredly requires
adulting harder than the people around
you sometimes i think founders look at
us and they're kind of like well you
know my roommates don't do this so why
do i have to and it's like well your
roommates aren't trying to build a
billion dollar company then they don't
have to but
maybe you need to be better than the
people around you to do something
extraordinary it's yet another thing
that distances you from your peers
and if you if your whole thing in life
is i'm the same as my peers and i'm the
same as my roommates that have jobs at
like big tech companies
this is yet another way that you're
going to be isolated and different and
have to learn to love that
and not
feel sad that when they're like hey
we're going to go
pull another all-nighter we're going to
go party thursday friday saturday
you have to be cool with opting out of
that
right yep but if you if you think you
can have it all
you can't i don't know if you can have
it all you can't we're here to tell
we're here to ruin that have it all
dream
so where i like to start is audit how
you live
like think about where you're waking up
in the morning you know did you get
enough sleep
are you in a a place that's
a home is it are you living in a place
that makes you more powerful
or less powerful
are you sacrificing like are you losing
hit points at home
you know and if that's happening man
that's unforced error right like so
that's
who you're living with
what you're eating do you have easy
access to exercise
are you know are you living in a place
with a bunch of alcohol and drugs
everywhere
you know not helping you like
at the minimum your home should be
neutral but i think for the most
successful people the home's actually a
plus like the home is like
where they're making points where
they're winning points and i think that
a lot of founders in their early days
don't understand how much they could be
losing based on just how they're living
yeah i think
almost from a clinician's perspective
when someone is having
issues the first thing you look at is
sleep disruption
diet and exercise right if you go if you
go look at you know research depression
or anxiety and things
that's usually
where the 80 20 solution is for a lot of
folks that are struggling is you look at
their sleep patterns
are they sleeping okay are they eating
okay are they getting exercise or
they're getting sun all these sorts of
things and so if you don't have your
house in order on those fronts
you are not
even if you don't currently have
depression
you are not well situated to deal with
really hard things that might happen to
you right
but dalton
i went to an ivy league school
and it was really hard and i went to a
really challenging high school and i
didn't have to change these things to
get good grades or to get the good
internship like i did you know i was
able to like work hard and play hard
why do i have to change now it's working
it's working for me this lifestyle
i think i think it can work for people
you and i know people that um certainly
don't follow this advice and they still
still did okay i just think you and i
also know the same people
where eventually you've got to pay the
piper
like at some point no matter it's almost
like you're going into debt like
personal health debt or whatever you
want to call it and man yes you can go
pretty far today you can go five years
in a debt you can go 10 years into debt
i don't know but at some point the debt
comes due
where you can't hold it all in anymore
you can't hold the whole world on your
shoulders and i think what we're just
trying to say is if you
start off with good habits early
you're not going to incur this massive
debt that one day causes you to have
like um a breakdown or a meltdown again
what do you want whatever you want to
call it
well and
to double down on that
i might argue that like
you probably can sacrifice these things
for five years like maybe even seven
years
the tricky thing is that like the best
companies last multiple decades the
tricky things is the [ __ ] that you can
get away with in your 20s you can't get
away with in your 30s
and
company running just gets harder and so
i think sometimes people are like oh
this is going to be a relative sprint
but it's like
what i like to talk to you about with yc
founders a lot is like what happens if
this works
like are you set up for this to not work
or are you set up for this to work
because this works like
you're going to be in it like you're
going to be in it for a while and i
think sometimes people set their lives
up for it to like not work and then wow
you know self-fulfilling prophecy and
when you think about it this isn't an
age thing this is a lifestyle thing
because you'll see like
19 year olds with all the good habits
and you'll see folks
that aren't 19
that like
i still live like 19 years and so this
isn't an age thing at all this is a
habits thing man
well and you'll even see successful
people with good habits lose them
and then wonder why they can't succeed
again right it's like even just having
these habits doesn't mean you keep them
so okay so that's so that's that's your
you know physical life style setup
you want to talk about this kind of
social media piece because i think that
a lot of people
don't understand how toxic social media
it's like
yeah i think i think you just want to
look at your information diet the
metaphor i think about this stuff with
is uh the same way we have a food diet
and like of course
what we eat and drink affects our moods
and how we feel i actually think the
information we consume
affects us and if you think about
again like myself all of us you know
when when it's a really heavy time in
history when there's a lot going on when
i'm doomed scrolling all the time
reading about pandemic news or war news
or whatever
of course that affects my state of mind
okay and so to some extent
you can't completely stick your head on
the ground about what's going on in the
world no one's saying to do that
but to the extent
your social media habits
make you feel bad or compare yourselves
to people
or say you follow a lot of like
investors and everything they're talking
about is the investment market and who's
raising all of that and this is just
every day you're bombarding your brain
with stuff about investor [ __ ]
why
why is that good why how is that helping
you actually run your startup
reading what a bunch of investors say
about the market
all the time and i think people are
surprised that like successful founders
like explicitly block social media they
do crazy things like
you know they they grayscale their phone
so it looks less interesting they turn
off notifications they're aggressive
users of like um
screen time like tracking like they they
actually
pretty aggressively audit this stuff so
that illiquidity saved you all and so
again so if you're consuming if you're
consuming media every day and you're
reassessing the value like if you're too
paying attention to this stuff it
doesn't make you make better financial
decisions does it
no isn't that wild
the next area i like to talk about is
salary
um
oftentimes
and and this is more of course for
companies that have raised funding
just a a small incremental five or ten
percent cal salary bump can make a huge
lifestyle difference
and and it's almost always worth it like
i think people screw up and this is what
i say to founders i'd love to hear your
advice
if your startup salary is allowing you
to save money
it's probably not good
right you shouldn't be sitting here like
with google employee level savings
running your startup
however if your startup salary is giving
you the lifestyle that
allows you to be all in on your startup
because the real world isn't distracting
you negatively
um then it is good and what's
interesting is that often for different
founders this is a different salary
level you know perfect example when i
was starting i had student loans in
college my co-founders didn't
i made a little bit more money so that i
wasn't like going into debt with my
student loans and that was
perfectly reasonable and no one was like
oh well you need to take x percent less
because you need to pay a 200 student
loan every month it's like no like
so
sometimes small changes in salary now
you know if you have a co-founder where
it's like i need to make a half a
million dollars a year and i'm 23.
yeah that's probably different but like
sometimes people are sacrificing
pennywise pound foolish right like
sometimes we're being pennywise pound
foolish
i think this is one of those topics also
like equity where what founders want to
hear
is here's the right answer one size fits
all for everyone or here's the formula
oh here's a spreadsheet
here we go michael here's how much to
pay yourselves just fill out the
spreadsheet and we're done like and
sadly like many things in life
anyone that tells you their simple
answers is probably trying to sell you
something you know like
[Laughter]
right they're like
yeah it's probably snake oil and
and so the subtlety that i agree with
you on is
you want to pay yourself enough that you
don't get into debt
you want to pay yourself enough so that
you're properly motivated you also want
to keep enough
you want to keep the money in the
company like these are all
variables that you have to turn and
you know if you're going to be a
successful founder you have to have good
judgment and you have to have opinions
and so when founders have no opinion
about this stuff
it's not a great sign so it's kind of
like you need a philosophy
of what you're solving for around
compensation you want to set everyone up
for success
yes a line incentives well and also
realize that this
this looks different for every company
man
like a lot of folks ask me well how much
should i pay employee number one i'm
like
that's a nonsensical question who are
they what's you know do you see what i'm
saying like like it's yeah like what
they want is some answer oh you should
pay employee number one x but like no
man that's like no
that's not how this works
it was almost easier to come to these
conclusions when i think back because we
didn't have very much money and so we
kind of had to tell me you know like
whenever anything's scarce you have to
ration it more effectively
and i think that like our philosophy
because i like what you're saying
there's no formula but we had a
philosophy which is like
salary is for living and equity is for
upside
like that's that was the kind of
philosophy
um
and i think that served us that served
us pretty well um
the next area of prevention
you have to learn how to have
hard conversations with your co-founders
and for everyone to be okay afterwards
um and
everyone has to go through this and it's
gonna suck but
if you have some of those in the bag
when you get punched in the face you all
know a little bit more how to interact
with each other
and
to me the biggest challenge that i've
seen on this front we've talked about
this at yc quite a bit
is
this um anxious
personality type versus avoid into
personality type you know when people
are challenged people are frustrated
and this is way oversimplification but
sometimes people are anxious they want
to deal with the problem right now
they're leaning in they want to talk for
they've talked for two hours with you
and they won't talk for another two
hours with you
and sometimes people are avoidant and
you know after five minutes they're done
they they want to think about it for a
long time they rather talk
asynchronously and i actually see that
most
problems between co-founders
the root cause isn't whatever went wrong
or whatever they're debating
it's actually their style of dealing
with their frustration
and if you can have a little empathy if
the person
who you're working with has a different
style of dealing with frustration than
you do
and you can just take a beat right i'm
the i'm the anxious type you know this
dalton like i'm super i want to like
talk about it for six hours then six
more hours i want to plan i want to
write it down
right now go go go go
and
i always get into trouble when i'm
interacting with someone who
reacts negatively to that and i always
have to kind of be like [ __ ] i gotta
take a beat like in this situation i
gotta take a beat
and so
in my experience
if you can figure out that dance with
your co-founder
it's so much more helpful when you're
dealing with these external challenges
and like the startup's going to present
many opportunities for frustration with
your co-founder
infinite opportunities
it's like the whole topic today which is
eventually you're going to take punches
you're going to have set back to your
startup
eventually you're going to have conflict
to the co-founder 100
100 like like and the thing that you're
disagreeing about isn't even the thing
like who cares it's noise
right like oh it's like roommates oh did
you take did you put the dishes away or
like it's not about the thing and like
it's not about who's right or who's
wrong and it's funny because a lot of
people want to ask us advice
about co-founder stuff but that what
they want to what they want is us to
agree that they were right and their
co-founder is wrong you love that
they're wrong dalton can i tell you
about the situation
basically
i'm smart my co-founder is dumb what do
you think i should do about it like it's
always and it's like no no no no i'm not
gonna take debate on that i'm sure
like the actual
thing that you need advice on a thing to
work on is the meta conversation which
is like how do you deal with conflict
so that people feel good
when it's over
yeah otherwise
whatever the you know not cleaning up
your dishes or taking the trash out
whatever the equivalent of that is in
your cofounder relationship
eventually it's not gonna work out man
right you gotta have tools no because
there's gonna be more issues
well i think that's what's fun about
this what is that like
early stage founders argue about the
dumbest things that there's almost
infinite opportunities to practice this
dealing with
frustration of your co-founder like it
is like a roommate relationship there's
infinite opportunities before something
that's a real whammy comes so like
take those opportunities like
please take them do you have any more on
the preventative side before we move the
treatment i think it's just this
expectation setting i think so much of
life is expectation setting where
setting expectations for yourself set
expectations for people you work with
about what to expect
if you are good at that
people can deal with all sorts of stuff
and when you get into the biggest
trouble both with yourself managing your
own brain as well as working with other
people is when you say a bunch of stuff
that is that turns out to be really not
true and you set expectations poorly and
you have to like
dig yourself out of this deep hole that
you dug yourself into because you
promised a bunch of [ __ ] or you set
expectations in such a way that just
weren't true
and so expectation setting is key for
prevention and you know we talked about
this in another video but man it's it
helps to study the real story of
companies right it helps just to just
know how long this takes
man it really helps for you to not have
stupid expectations oh well this company
became a billion dollar company in two
years so that's clearly the average path
and it's like no like absolutely not
absolutely not
it's funny because in some ways you're
saying sometimes these companies punch
themselves out right like they don't
even need external forces they set a
stupid expectation they don't hit their
own unrealistic expectation then they
feel like something's wrong and you're
just like holy crap you just invented a
crisis like startups have enough crises
without that
well
we've talked about all the things you
can do to prevent the injury let's say
the punch happens bam
and you need some treatment
something really bad happens or you
suspect something really bad happens
um
i think the first point that you brought
up
that i really love is this idea of like
do i have to do anything right now
like
talk about that a little bit more yeah i
think i learned this as a founder the
hard way which is when something bad
happens you want to immediately
like
make a move you want to like call a
meeting or you want you get a you get an
email
with bad news in it you want to hit
respond and like
in the moment of fight or flight when
your adrenaline's pumping you're like
how dare you sir you know
you want to
you want to get start writing emails
with that tone dear sir
in response to your query about
you know like if you're ever typing an
email with that tone like
you know don't do it um
and what i've noticed is you can just
like
not respond or like let stuff sit a
little bit
and
sleeping on it is the minimum thing i
would do this is what i always tell
founders is when they have something to
happen to at least sleep on it
because i just noticed
the next day
you have a whole new amount of clarity
on the situation and i and i often find
myself in my best moments in my worst
moments and exactly like you said i'm
like act now go
send that email like punch back and my
best moments i'm always like
if there's ever a decision that feels
like it's action one or action two
there's always a third option which is
don't act there's all like and it's
almost never presented to you um i find
a lot of times lawyers [ __ ]
companies with this it's like you gotta
do this or that and it's like it's not
like
how about we don't what if we do nothing
yes
and then what's really funny is that
like the best founders
no action becomes one of their like key
plays like they use that play way more
than you think
it's a great play it's such a good play
um and it's amazing that like for the
best founders no action is like you know
20 30 40 of the time what they do maybe
more
but for other founders they don't even
know the play exists
like they don't even know the play
exists yeah maybe just archive the email
yeah whatever the email says
yeah that's true just hit them you know
it's a really big deal they'll probably
reply back
i've noticed that
it's a really big deal
um and of course don't do this in the
case where someone's health is on the
line or someone's gonna go to jail or
whatever right that's different but um
yeah it's more of like
the stuff
where someone where it's like
interpersonal or someone
i don't know
yeah someone said something bad
that you you can't archive you can wait
till the weekend's over to reply to that
slack message like it's gonna it'll
it'll survive so the next one on the
list is it's okay to take a day off it's
okay
to go home
i think that you know
there was one moment in my career where
um we were gonna get bought uh socialcam
was gonna get bought
and we were two months into the
diligence process
and
we got a call that said the deal was off
and it was the only moment in my career
where i was like
i'm not going to react to this well in
front of my co-founders
i just need to go
home at least home i can react
in a way that won't be a bad example to
them
you know like because they're going to
look in my reaction they're going to be
like are we [ __ ] and if i'm looking
like we're [ __ ]
that's not helping you know when the
generals like pulling their hair being
like this looks horrible we're gonna die
that's not good
um
and man like going home
um
hanging out with you know at the time
was my girlfriend but then you know
later became my wife like
taking that day the next day i could
kind of bring a better michael to the
table yeah right
you know
that was that was a big thing that was a
big thing
um
i i was thinking about this in the
context of like
when things go bad
there's a current inside a p set of
people you should probably be hanging
out with and a certain set of people you
probably shouldn't be hanging out with
right like how do you think about that
yeah i mean again we
i have my personal experience and i have
all the data points we have across yc
founders and you just sometimes see
people
that are that are taking punches and
having a hard time and there's some
really amazing people that you can hang
out with that support you and tell you
you're okay and validate your experience
and like
let you take space for yourself and like
all this good stuff and like these are
these are great people to have in your
life and then we see other sorts of
folks that are like
you know oh you should do tons of drugs
um or
hey like let's go
not sleep for a really long amount of
time or let's hang out with celebrities
or like you know like there's all these
different crowds you can get into
and
it's
depressing
how predictive that is for how people
will deal with like setbacks
you know yeah even and these are adults
we're not even talking we're talking
about
these are they're adults these are
our grown people our age people
still struggle with this particular one
um and so i think you just want to think
about
yeah who who you're spending time with
when you're
when you're taking punches and what kind
of habits that you're taking from the
peer group you know what man i really
think that the best people you know i'll
be explicit right the best people [ __ ]
goes wrong and they go take a hike or
something
and the worst people think [ __ ] goes
wrong and they drink and do drugs and
like it tends to be that those friend
groups
you know for a lot of founders you know
the friends who if you go out with them
you're going to drink and do drugs and
you know the other friends where if you
go out then you're going to go on a hike
like
just explicit you know and
you know but pick the right group
you know pick the right group
um and it's weird because i don't think
the friends are bad they're not trying
to harm you you know
well they're doing their own thing
yeah
um it's just that you know you have to
choose the right
therapy
you have to choose the right therapy for
yourself and and actually this that's a
good segue like
let's talk about real health care let's
talk about mental health care for a
second like you know
this is this is becoming less of a
controversial issue but i still think
that it's something that needs to be
normed more right
yeah i mean
therapy is good medication is good if
you're prescribed it and it's not from
your friend just kidding um
[Laughter]
you know this is
this stuff is destigmatized and it's
it's important and like a lot of
founders struggle i think it's the ups
and the downs exacerbate this stuff and
again the stuff i said earlier
um sleep disruption stress all these
other things exacerbated so
you know
sometimes
that is the appropriate thing to do here
so you should
do it and not think you're too tough or
whatever whatever reason it would be
that you wouldn't
use these things as a crutch i just i've
noticed that people that aren't
the people that aren't willing to use
this stuff they find other crutches that
yeah i would not do that
right well and i think that most people
don't realize this isn't the kind of
stuff that that comes out in your
favorite company's press release
most people don't realize how the
founders who
they are impressed with actually take
advantage of therapy actually take
advantage of medication
most people don't realize you know their
founders i know who've sworn off
drinking because like they are not
good you know they they're not the best
version themselves when they're drinking
like this isn't the kind of stuff that
people will talk about very publicly but
we know a lot of people and
when someone's trying to squeeze every
ounce of positive productivity out of
themselves
sometimes like you know um
they need to use these tools and it's
really helpful
really really helpful
so
you know let's talk about
the fatal punches right you know why i
see we do with a lot of failure we deal
with a lot of companies who fail
and
you and i have to have a lot of
conversations with founders who
their company has failed and their first
thought is i'm a failure they
personalize that failure
what are the some of the things you tell
those people when they're dealing with
that fatal punch
yeah i think it as per we talked about
here
a lot of the things that people think
are game over aren't and so our advice
is don't give up like you actually have
a bunch of customers you have a bunch of
money like let's look at the facts
you're good and so a lot of our office
hours are let's examine the facts
fact fact fact fact great you're
fine however
sometimes we look at the facts and
you're not fine
and it doesn't help you
like you don't need a pep talk to keep
going
and
it actually is probably the right thing
for you to not keep going
because at the end of the day
this is your life you only have one of
them
and messing up your life
in a permanent way
your savings your family your friends
whatever it is you know don't do that
and again i know it can be confusing out
there because we get bombarded with
messages oh but you say you never give
up or you say you know like
yeah it's confusing it's that easy
yeah it's complicated yeah complicated
so i think you need to actually with
this
clear objective
ways as you can be able to know when
it's not working
and that it was a fatal punch and that
yeah you should
not do this anymore like sometimes
sometimes you see people get into like
debt where they owe a bunch of people a
lot of money and then they shut down and
they ripped off all their suppliers
again you know you know what i'm trying
to say like like you could you fail in
such a way that you hurt a bunch of
people not just yourself
not good don't do that when i think that
this is what's tricky is that i think
someone needs to be out there saying
that these aren't the things you have to
put on the table to win
yes when you're working hard you're
gonna probably have to spend less time
with your family or friends but you
don't have to put those relationships
you don't have to sacrifice those
relationships to win in fact they're a
source of strength you're working hard
you're probably not saving as much money
as you would be if you're working
another job but you don't have to
sacrifice all your savings you don't
have to go into extreme debt
like
if you're working hard like
you might not be able to get the salary
that allows you to live in the apartment
of your dreams
but like if you have to crash on friends
couches
these things
don't tend to have to be sacrificed to
win and so if you're if you're taking
these kind of one-way hard
life hits
maybe the facts are are set up yeah and
again what's tough
is when you're one of those folks
sometimes you can even be victimized by
people that'll like
keep
bleeding you because that's the racket
and we see this a lot with struggling
startups all sorts of people will come
out of the woodwork to sell you services
or promise they'll connect with the
investors or they'll help you fundraise
or you name it
and it's like it's kind of like
moving to hollywood to become an actor
and it's not going well all these people
will
like there's a whole underbelly of folks
who exist to sell stuff rip off the
people who aren't doing well
you know to me
where i see this happen that's most
tragic is with non-technical founders
because it'll be some dev shop or some
you know
if you give me your last dollar i
promise that
i'll solve your problem
yeah you see people
writing checks for
20 30 40 what are 50 grand out of their
personal checking account their life
savings to some dev shop yes that's like
their whole business model is to rip i
shouldn't say rip but like they're like
yeah cool like whatever like just as
long as the check clears we'll do it you
know yeah it's pretty depressing
that's really depressing
and and i think that like
those founders when we have this
conversation be like hey
your startup failed that doesn't mean
you failed you know sometimes they just
need to hear someone say that like
so often
we'll talk about like look at this
person they're sort of fail and they
have another one that does well look at
this person they should have failed and
they're not working as an executive at
this really cool company like these
experiences you have
are valuable to you even if your company
didn't work you know
you learned 10x more than you would have
learned otherwise even if your company
didn't work
and sometimes when we explain that
silver lining people are like oh
you're right
you know
that's actually a fun part of the job
so there you go
step one how to try to avoid the punches
or step two when they come
how to recover as fast as possible
great shine today dalton thanks man
[Music]
[Music]